Next question, by stools have been hard these past couple weeks, which is abnormal for me. I still have in two to three all moments per day, but I'm having a lot of gas, which is very embarrassing any advice.
So whatever you're having hard stools, the first thing you think of is, are you drinking enough water? Okay, because if you're dehydrated, you could have hard stools.
Digestive enzymes in hydrochloric acid are another first thing you think of. So the other thing that will help pull water into the bowel is magnesium.
So the reason why a person takes magnesium that has looser stools is because you have a need for magnesium in your body.
Matter of fact, probably if any other nutrient there is magnesium is utilized in more metabolic pathways than anything else.
However, any excess magnesium will just be dumped back into the colon that magnesium because it's a positive iod will draw water to it.
So if you take more magnesium than you need, then you will dump it into the colon. It draws water and you will loosen your stools.
So one of the easiest way, if you have real difficult stools, you have hard stools, constipation by first go to is add magnesium.
Start taking some magnesium before bed, you'll usually have looser stools just because it'll draw water, but you can't be dehydrated either. So make sure you're drinking enough water also.
You can have hard stools and especially this last hint about lots of gas because you're not getting proper digestion.
If you're getting a lot of gas, you're getting food that's sitting in your colon and your small intestine longer than it should and it's fermented and then that fermentation is causing gas.
So different foods will ferment quickly. That's why eating beans or something like that are gassy foods, quote unquote, because they ferment quickly.
So you have to ask yourself, what's your diet like? Am I eating a lot of these foods that ferment or as food gestated my colon longer, we may have a longer intestine of transit time.
Therefore, it has more time to ferment and I'm not getting enough digestive enzymes in. So adding digestive enzymes, adding HCl hydrochloric acid with each meal when you eat your food is when you take the HCl, you can take digestive enzymes right then too much take digestive enzymes anytime.
Make sure you have enough water consumption and then make sure you add made these you so those are the things that I would suggest for that issue.